rich thanks for joining us we'll get to
the the actual tournament here in a
moment
but we did have a question here have you
been on Tiger Woods yacht privacy I have
not been on privacy I found it odd
yesterday that Tiger was asked about
being docked in Sag Harbor and what did
he think of the town he said you know
it's a cute little town I haven't had a
chance to walk around but I hope to like
Friday afternoon after dropping 69 Tiger
is going to be walking around Sag Harbor
shopping for raspberry soap and one of a
kind greeting cards in the cute little
town I mean this is Tiger 2.0 this is
the comfortable relaxed
Tiger Woods not the grinded out step on
your neck Tiger Woods now I've not been
on the dinghy as he calls it privacy
do you know somebody who's been on the
dinghy I do not would you tell me if you
did with the beautiful people in the
Hamptons it's not my scene I mean I'm
more of a grinder yeah I'm a meat and
potatoes kind of guy I have not looked
like the best region for golf maybe in
the world yeah this stretch I covered
the 86 US Open with Raymond Floyd and I
wasn't playing golf at the time and I
just remember how interesting that was
because I had been to Europe I'd been to
you know Scotland and Ireland and seen
those courses but I saw Shinnecock and
it was something different so fascinated
by it and was was there in 1986 him well
with my group I had a moment a couple of
weeks ago late in the day playing I had
that that moment of reflection where you
look out the Sun is setting and you
think wow this is golf and then I turned
around and my buddy was taking a pee and
a bush
and I thought this is would you rather
win the Masters US Open or British Open
if I said the US Open was at Pebble the
British Open at st. Andrews or you could
win the Masters Masters me too yeah I
can say the open in the elements I'd
like to win the open in the elements I'd
like to have you know I could I got
sweat Iran and I'd like to hear the old
commentators late great commentator Alex
as I walked up 18 you know he's on the
foot under power now he's he's come from
three adrift and now he's about to go
around in 67 strokes to win the Claret
Jug you know that would be one of the
great feelings in sports and I've talked
to players about this is is walking up
18 or the 72nd hole of a major
championship you know $10 on each side
and behind the green and you have a
two-stroke lead and you take the cap off
and just soak it in for the final 40 50
yards up that last fairway that must be
an amazing feeling we haven't talked too
much about Tiger recently and I I don't
know I think there was there was hope by
the media because they wanted to cover
something different and or you know
something they had covered before but
Tigers realistic chances at Shinnecock
are what I'd be surprised if he won no
because I think his body of work since
he came back start of the year has been
pretty good to top dogs he had two
decent chances to win Valspar when he
made that putt in the 71st hole and then
as well at Bay Hill he I think he he
needs to drive it better
he needs to putt better those are the
two obvious like he can't drive it all
over the planet the rough is too high
here and obviously he has to putt like
old tiger he has to make pretty much
everything or 90% of everything he looks
at from
inside of 10 feet or inside of 5 feet if
he's not puting like old tiger I don't
think he's gonna have a great chance in
there an NHL referee who's who's playing
in the US Open not in the field I
thought there was an NHL referee who
qualified for the US Open it's possible
you'll forgive me I I'm not aware of
that and shame on me I apologize they
thinking of Brett thinking of referees
across there like now a baseline rule
where you have to be jack you have to be
like a massive bodybuilder to be an
official in the NBA or the NFL
what's vanity now because you're on TV
yeah yeah Fritzie who do we have is the
officials name his name is Garrett rank
he's actually gonna join you on Friday
on the show and he show refuge for the
US Open is you can get stories like that
you get 17 year old and get this kid no
a Goodwin you can get you know the rep
and get an NHL official you get a
mailman
if you're good enough you can qualify
and they had almost 10,000 people sign
up to try to qualify for the US Open and
we still call in and rat people out is
there still a hotline or is that over
that's kind of over we'll have officials
now watching how do you feel about no no
whatever happens happens and if somebody
misses it they missed it you know yeah I
don't want Big Brother watching here if
there's too many armchair officials as
it is and then you give them validation
you know then people are gonna be
calling in or emailing all the time and
thinking they saw something and they
don't even know the rules but no if
Tigers if Tigers of followers pick up a
rock and move it and nobody calls it in
the moment then you know what play on
you're right with that we have our draft
tomorrow and this is a what is it three
round four round draft here polling so
we want to know some of the people that
you like and obviously the favorites but
if there's any sneaky pick so number one
overall pick if you had the first pick
to win the US Open rich Lerner from the
golf channel would take and wasn't
creative no 300ml consistently hit high
and soft like he does and he drives a
pretty straight he's putting well really
confident
I love Dustin Johnson's game I mean he
is he's the pitcher who strikes out the
side
on nine pitches high heat 103 on the gun
and then just centers to the dugout like
nothing happened he's the coolest dude
in the sport and what I think's
interesting about him as years ago you
remember when he sort of blew it at
Whistling Straits yeah bunker do you
remember that and wastelander majors
that he let get away in the early days
he was kind of viewed as as nuke LaLoosh
from Bull Durham million-dollar arm and
a five cent head and I don't mean to be
cool but that was just a view now that
was unfair because it turns out he
actually has a really good head for golf
in that he lets things roll off his back
he doesn't sweat stuff and that's
important at a US Open because you're
going to get screwed you're going to get
a bad break you're gonna especially this
week on these greens your bumpy putts on
the power so he's obviously much more
than nuclear he's legit ease when he's
going to end up being like a 30 to 35
wind guy when all is said and done if he
stays healthy I mean he'll be among the
20 best players ever if he doesn't get
hurt when he's all said and done anyway
I like Dustin I like Ricky and
and I think you know a good value play
is Patrick Reed at thirty to one stay
away from who should I absolutely stay
away from I'm gonna give you a guy and
he's gonna end up winning stay away from
will probably stay away from mmm put me
on the spot here and I'm trying to thank
him and I like I like Jason dice got a
great record at the US Open you looking
at if you shouldn't who would you take
if I said Phil or tiger I would probably
lean towards still okay I would lean
towards so Jordan speith are you all in
on jordan Spieth this week I mean I'm
[Music]
concerned about his padding I mean this
is it's almost hard to fathom and this
guy made everything he looked at he was
Tiger 2.0 and now he's 190th and that
cutting stat they had strokes gained
putting but that said he has an you know
athletes sense for the big moment and
you just need to think about what he did
sunday at the Masters I don't long-term
worry about Jordan and I you know he's a
great player who's in a sort of a funk
with his putting right now if he can get
out of his head and get into being an
athlete and he's a really good athlete
he'll be fine but I'm loving because I
don't think he's in a great place but
that said would I be shocked
no you never shocked with a guy like
Jordan because he he rises to the
occasion
the big one rich good to talk to you
I'll be watching later on tonight I'll
be critiquing you know things like how
your tie looks you know just simple
things like that so I'm watching and
writing
down notes that I then hand into golf
channel management I understand that
how's the school going that's great yeah
enjoy land oh yeah a lot of fun we we'd
love to have you come over and and talk
to the students that'd be great you know
and that would be great
please repeat last li who is your pick
to win the open I can't say it now
because we have a draft tomorrow and
then you know the Dan nets are then
going to take that and then it might
come back and haunt me and did you guys
I think paulie's accepted the fact that
he didn't sign his scorecard whether he
you know the other Dennett's were helped
in signing their scorecard but Paulie
didn't sign his scorecard so I think
Fritzi somehow won there is going to be
a rematch though
McLovin forgot to put down a score for
18 and so he'd was DQ'd Pauly D Q so
Fritzi won and then there's going to be
a rematch here and probably a shower
shame attached to that so the stakes
will be very very high possibly a
segment for Chamblee and Knobble o on
live from I would love that has to get
Randall to run the numbers on thank you
rich we'll be watching tonight that's
rich Lerner rich Lerner Golf Channel
host for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]